[Music]
in dream destroyer news dream destroyers
because the who dick dreamer is no man
rock oh wait that's his name is Nick
dreamer but his is a man or someone else
right hitman breaker yeah submitted by
hashtag I stand with dreamers dreamer
the Trump administration has scraped the
dreamers program for immigrant children
living the United States what does that
mean what is the means if you're
immigrant parents came over and brought
you along with them and even if you're
like two years all the time now I think
you can get like deported for that he
barked it that's all there was a federal
program those created back in 2012 under
Obama called the deferred action for
childhood arrivals aka daca and so that
would allow you that were brought into
the United States illegally to
temporarily have the right to live work
and study legally but you have to be
younger than 31 to apply to this program
but you had to have been 16 or younger
when you came into the United States so
first they get better for criminal
activity and if they pass and their
deportation was put off for two years
and so they also get a chance to renew
it and to become eligible for driver's
license college enrollment and worked
all that's time those protected under
this act or called dreamers and so
almost 800,000 people have already been
approved and they're already considered
dreamers this program was created as a
compromise between the Obama
administration and after Congress had
already failed to approve a similar act
that would have offered illegal children
permanent legal residency so then this
is kind of a compromise but just
recently the Trump administration
announced that the they would end this
policy in March of 2018 which would be
fulfilling his campaign promises and
because of the fact that Obama created
this as an executive order policy Trump
has the power to just reverse it
and so now Trump has given Congress six
months to come up with a solution to
resolve all of this and so he's saying
that the government will generally not
take actions to remove current
law-abiding dreamers so that's kind of
where we're at right now so whoever was
already a dreamer is cool but anybody
after is [ __ ] there's no more
applications are being accepted oh wow
that's not too bad there's no one
getting [ __ ] that's already in the
program well that's the thing when this
first was announced because it wasn't
clear really and so a lot of people were
just really scared a lot of these
dreamers they don't know where they
stand but just recently like Trump
tweeted out like you know if you're a
dreamer don't worry nothing's gonna
happen but still a lot of people are
against this because you know immigrants
they create our country like the maker
yeah great and so not only that but then
the country is gonna lose out of
millions of dollars in taxes because
these people take they pay taxes and
they they contribute to society and so
this would be this would be a big effect
on my country I'm surprised it took us
this long all the way to 2012 to create
this act well they had been trying since
2007 I believe because you know the
government it takes [ __ ] forever for
them to get [ __ ] done I don't know why
it was a bipartisan thing to both
parties see everyone loves democracy and
all that [ __ ] but like look how long it
just takes for [ __ ] to happy oh all I'm
saying is man just have Jamal Young be a
dictator exactly colinear
get I'll just get it done mm-hmm I mean
a perfect example of how the government
runs is the DMV just takes [ __ ]
forever dude for some reason this
reminds me azmuth we've had something to
do it but not really but there's like
this thing on Vice is going around where
this is one of the like the vice
reporters he's like a light-skinned
black dude and he's interviewing like
hardcore white supremacist [ __ ] makes me
laugh I supposed to be very serious but
I'm cracking up because it's like this
person who sounds like there's a banjo
behind him with the wheat coming up with
nothing well let's just put it on here
all right
I'm more a far superior than you
[ __ ] those I'm more superior than you in
every single way I'm smarter than you
I'm stronger than you it's like a joke
the funny thing is like those white
supremacist guys they don't even
represent normal white people I think
why so extreme yeah they're looking at
him like these [ __ ] again please no
right it's like they they they they
think that they're that rich white guy
y'all gonna see same thing as him so
they're not they're nowhere they're not
even the same thing like your whole
family put together has one tooth total
and if you look at them like at all at
the protesters they're not like handsome
big good-looking normal white people
they're like the losers and then what
sucks is the media is like representing
them is oh look at these are all all
right white groups and then they're not
the face of white people they're just is
that they have a such a loud voice right
now and they're giving the bad image to
a lot of yeah there are the white people
that other white people don't want to be
associated with yeah in a conversation
that I had and this wasn't supposed to
be funny once again but it made me laugh
and he was like so you're saying that we
should have a genocide right as she goes
yes it's exactly what her husband's like
no comment on that I want my kids to
grow up in a white white society how it
should be there should be a genocide and
the guy and the camera pans over the guy
he goes yeah we're going back with this
daca so they are saying though that all
dreamers will lose their status by March
2020 and they will run the risk of being
deported to their country of birth so
it's so old dreamers can stay like if
someone came over here in 2000 whatever
at two years old they can stay or 19 I
meet somebody know now that well see the
thing is if Congress doesn't pass a
legislation allowing you know additional
temporary permanent legal status and
that's when the work that Obama's
administration did will just be gone and
people now run the risk of being
deported now they have that shadow of
deportation over them once again
fighting when you're brought over here
at like one years old man oh well you
know yeah oh you don't even know the
country where you were born you know the
language I wonder though the real reason
why
immigration is criminalized
so like for example in the past there
were no real like you don't have to
certify er like I mean like people just
came in in droves and then they just got
dropped off in New York no paper and
then people just came in and and I don't
know if it's a population thing now
we're we're like maxed out or social
services or all the things that
immigrants need is like there's too much
money being spent if they can give us a
legit answer why this is happening I
think it's a lot better because
everything is being is is being like a
race issue it's like oh we just don't
want illegals here or whatever I need to
know like why I think that reason is
probably a worser reason than race is
probably why they're not telling you
yeah it's probably like they're running
out of money or they need more money or
during the Vietnam war on people came
over the refugees was that that's is
that considered asylum they sought
asylum here wasn't that a refugee that
was it was a government thing
yeah they allowed the refugee in okay
like so right now they're not allowing
the refugees in from the Middle East
yeah but I think back then America
backed out backed up South Vietnam yeah
and then when South Vietnam loss in
America ran away from all that then they
they were like well since you know we
had your back you guys could come in
yeah so going back home you're you're
saying like why are they so against this
apparently conservatives are really
against daca because they're saying that
it's unconstitutional and that dreamers
are illegal and a beep threatened
American jobs and like the whole
American society how is that
unconstitutional because first of all
everyone came here with no papers
there's all the ancestors of white
people
here with no papers and there's a lot of
people in the early 1900s even in a
recent history that basically didn't
need to have Social Security or whatever
they just came in and you know there's
Americans that were in America for many
many generations that that didn't have a
Social Security number until it was in I
don't know if you're gonna depart my ass
you better [ __ ] teach me how to speak
Korean completely fluently teach me all
about Korea then I move my ass back
there I can't go there like I'm an
immigrant you know well I'm a citizen
now I think what it yeah my dad was
actually worried about this [ __ ] so he's
not like the country change and he goes
okay well we're gonna change your name
legally to David now and then I need you
to get your citizenship so all of us got
our citizenship like what like about
seven years ago
how long does that take I heard it takes
years well it was back then it was
pretty quick South Korea to again that
takes decades exactly we're like a
companion and so it took at this time to
I think like it cost us like 600 bucks a
pop and before it was like a hundred
something and so it was way more
expensive but my dad was I was gonna pay
it and so like seven or eight years ago
he paid it for all of us and then we
exactly so my dad surprised he was right
she saw it coming
I remember quizzing my aunt for her
immigration like immigration papers so
sometimes i lurk on the alt-right and
like i kind of see like great Bart Musa
yeah I mean like Infowars and all those
I just kind of creeped in there because
I think you want to see I just want to
see how they like what's going on what
they're thinking and besides the alien
stuff and the conspiracy stuff if you
try to boil down what's really going on
it's like there's a there's a motive
there's a reason why people hate right
they don't they don't just hate you cuz
you you walk down the street that like
look at that [ __ ] chain there's a
reason for people's hate and then I
think the main reason why humans hate is
because they feel threatened or
something's being taken away from them
so like when you know the whole tech in
our job thing
sure they know that there are immigrants
that come to this country and then they
trick the system with the social
services they pop out mad kids and then
they stay on welfare for like three four
generations and they get all this like
government money and so they qualify for
these things just based off of race not
for anything else and then there are
white people that have been in this
country for many generations that
because they're white they can't get the
social services middle-class to maybe
even poor white males they don't qualify
for certain financial aid and stuff for
college and all that stuff but then
minorities get it just for the sake of
being minorities they don't even have to
be poor and they see that firsthand and
they go what the [ __ ] dude like how come
they get it just based off of race so I
can really start understanding their
point of view why they're so angry but
at the same time I think it's like when
you see things on the bottom level you
don't see it from the top level and it
just it causes all this [ __ ] fighting
it's in human nature to be right like we
all want to be right and so from their
perspective they think they're right and
they're not trying to listen to the
other side of this I think what we
really gotta do is just listen to each
other because it's like why the hell I
think we're right now what's happening
is you know when you when you click
online right like all the news that you
do like it's it's like that algorithm
yeah oh I like karate a lot so a lot of
karate is gonna pop up so what I didn't
realize is like based off of your
location and the [ __ ] that you click a
lot that's the kind of news you get yeah
so we get a lot of liberal news you know
turn that off I [ __ ] hate that
especially when I'm trying to find stuff
for news I'm like God everything's just
like cake blazing video no Facebook I
need us the articles but I hate that
yeah because I want to see the both bolt
I want to see both sides and then have a
discussion yeah instead of like right
now it's hella polarizing because like
you got people who live in a red state
who only get red news and they think
that [ __ ] non-whites are all the enemy
and they're ruining this country and
then you've got the people in the
the inner cities that get all left news
go to like colleges that only teach that
white people are evil and all this stuff
and then they grow up thinking like okay
you're the [ __ ] enemy no you're the
[ __ ] enemy so it's it's really stupid
I would like some political news on my
[ __ ] I keep on getting animals [ __ ]
karate yeah I even I like a lot of those
pages like the right-wing Facebook pages
and I'm always like why does it not pop
up in my feet I have to go to their page
and then read their articles because if
you get interested in like let's say
female activism or whatever and you
click that 15 times and you read those
articles now the algorithm just shows
that [ __ ] and it doesn't show the other
[ __ ] or like when I was in Tucson
Arizona like even the videos that you
watch like you know when you're
scrolling through your feed and the
videos just automatically play even if
you just scroll past that like it counts
as a view as a view and and so the
algorithm thinks that that's the kind of
stuff you like to watch and I'm like no
and I don't give me this like Facebook
has a change that [ __ ] cuz like oh I
hate it no but anyways like some
positivity to this story is that
companies have stated that they will not
fire their employees like their dreamer
employees and that they will offer legal
protection so for example Microsoft they
are committed to 39 dreamers employed by
them and that they will vigorously
defend them and that they would provide
and pay for their legal counsel and
Apple will also provide lawyers to their
250 dreamers that they haven't oh that's
darling that's coming yeah so at least
some positivity there but some good PR
have to be birthday do you want a dream
able to do something about this it could
be a positive solution for everyone hey
guys thanks for watching that last video
make sure to follow us on instagram @ JK
films to watch more videos right up
there
[Music]